every morning thousands of dogs wake up  not for a day of barks and naps but to  work more than half a million people  rely on a service dog in their everyday  lives but these are no ordinary pups a  dog's journey from carefree puppy to  hero is a long one filled with trials  triumphs and setbacks it takes months  and years to train these elite dogs for  all the rigors of service dog life and  not all puppies that begin the process  will graduate follow along as a handful  of puppies go through a month of  training obstacles and field trips all  to get just that much closer to  graduation  there's steady deacon charismatic Luke  Shai Benelli confident Kaia wild card  Remmy and of course the undeniable mr.  pip do any of these puppies have the  smarts and spirit to pass service dog  school find out in puppy prep  [Music]  you  [Music]